hello everyone and welcome to the
precision medicine virtual event my name
is rod samara i'm an associate director
in the global product management team
occasion and i will be presenting on the
chiastic expanded carrier screening
panel please feel free to submit
questions during my presentation and I
will follow up with you via email this
part this presentation will be broken
into two pieces I will go through the
chemistry part of the panel and then
we'll particular jump in to speak about
the bioinformatics piece and to start
off for the for the chemistry part I
thought we would start off with the
issue that we commonly see in library
preparation approaches I've broken down
the issues into four main categories
primer dimers specificity of enrichment
and sequencing the uniformity of
enrichment and sequencing and keeps your
duplicates and errors and then next I
basically explain why these are why
these are why these issues are
significant and what the consequences
are basically for primer dimers what you
end up with is the lack of covers across
your regions of interest
why is specificity of enrichment an
issue it's because it would be
associated with a higher cost per sample
and the same goes for uniformity if you
have a load more uniformity across your
regions of interest you end up with a
higher cost per sample PCR duplicates
and errors are a problem or an issue
simply because they could end up with
inaccurate variant analysis so what
we've done at Kaizen to overcome these
issues and consequences is to build some
solutions that would address each one of
these issues and these solutions are
part of what we call the chi seek
solution and these solutions are
basically a single primer extension
approach for enrichment which which can
get over the de primer dimers issue and
I will go into single primer extension
on all of these elements and solutions
in subsequent slides and basically to
overcome the issue of specificity and a
higher cost per sample we've built
industry-leading primer designs that
allow us to achieve a very high degree
of specificity across the regions of
interest and in order to also overcome
the issue of uniformity where we're
incorporating single primary function
approaches for enrichment that will
allow us to achieve a higher degree of
deformity as you will see in subsequent
slide as well and to overcome the issue
of PCR duplicates or errors we've
incorporated unique molecular indices or
um eyes into our library structures with
your minds we can now go back to with
powerful data analysis tools and analyze
data not just basically based on row
reads but we can now analyze data based
on unique molecular indices which will
allow us again to achieve a much more
accurate variant analysis as you'll see
in subsequent slide to highlight how
single primer extension approaches work
I thought I would I would compare a
single primer extension approach which
is a spin on amplicon type of approaches
I would compare how a single primer
extension approaches work compared to
the traditional two primer amplicon
design and so on the left-hand side you
see the two primer amplicon design in
which two regional specific primers are
required to enrich for that specific
region so for instance if you're
interested in exon 21 of EGFR or any
other gene for that matter with a 2
primer amplicon design you would require
2 EGFR exon 21 specific primers one that
flanks the beginning of the site that
you're interested in and one the flanks
at the end of that of that specific
region now the outcomes of of such an
approach well this has been a widely
used approach there are several
limitations of such an approach first
you end up with an increased risk of
primer dimers and dropouts and what this
translates to is of course you end up
not covering that specific region or you
end up covering it very poorly another
issue that we see is a lower degree of
uniformity in a lot of instances if you
have continuous stretches of genomic
regions that you want to cover end up
with multiple pools of primers that
would be required to cover all of the
regions that you're interested in and
then you end up with a low library
complexity simply because your start and
stop positions are defined by primers
and now increasing the panel content
might require primary design again this
goes back to that very first point of
increased primer risk that increased
risk of primer dimers if you want to
increase the panel content you'd have to
come back and basically ask the question
though
those new primers that I'm adding into
the panel how do they affect the
performance of existing primers so the
solution to this kind of issue is the
the single primer extension approach
that we've that we've incorporated into
the classic solution or SPE with single
primer extension basically it still is
an apple con based approach however when
you are trying to define your regions of
interest you don't need two primers to
define a region of interest anymore all
you need is just one region specific
primer the other primer that will be
used for the amplicon based approach is
basically a universal primer that binds
two sequences introducing the library
adapters and so if I go back to exon 21
of EGFR as an example again I do not
need to define exon 21 of EGFR with two
primers anymore all I need is just one
EGFR exon 21 specific primer and then
the other primer will be the universal
primer that will bind to to the library
sequences or the sequences introducing
the adapters what this allows us to do
now is to lower the risk of primer
dimers it allows us to increase the
uniformity of enrichment and sequencing
again as you'll see in a little bit and
this also allows us to pull all of the
required primers into a single port
primer so you do not need to split your
primers into multiple pools anymore it
allows us to achieve a higher library
complexity because be it's only the
start position that is defined the end
position of enrichment is going to be
defined randomly by this Universal
primer and now increasing the panel
content does not require a complete
redesign of existing primers you can if
you if you decide to forward or for
whatever reason if you decide to
increase the content of your panel you
don't have to redesign existing panels
anymore you can just take the new
primers that are required for the new
genes or new regions of interest and
simply spike them into the existing
primers so that way increasing that the
panel content does not really require a
complete rework of the of existing
primers
so how do unique molecular indices work
first so so I've gone over how a single
primer extension approaches differ from
the traditional two primer and which one
approaches and what I would like to do
next is to go over how unique molecular
indices allow us to achieve a higher
level of quantification of variants and
transcripts as well as how it would help
us get over the the issue of duplicates
PCR duplicates and errors so when it
comes to the quantification unique
military indices can help us achieve
this higher level and more accurate type
of quantification because we are not
counting just raw reads we are actually
counting unique original molecules that
have been tagged by unique molecular
indices before any enrichment takes
place so if I use this example of trying
to quantify let's say transcripts
mapping back to or reads mapping back to
exon 21 or V GFR in order to get an
accurate quantification level of a EGFR
gene on the top part of this slide you
see you see the scenario where we're
using just simple raw lead as a way to
count you know the levels of EGFR based
on exon 21 the issue that we see with
this type of approach is that when you
look at these five reads that map back
to exon 21 out of EGFR you really cannot
tell whether these represent five unique
DNA or RNA molecules or they're just
basically quintuplets of the same DNA or
RNA molecule that was just you know
amplified over and over so you can't
really tell what are you looking at PCR
duplicates or true fragments with unique
molecular indices that you introduced
before any amplification takes place and
I'll go through the workflow in a little
bit when you introduce unique molecular
indices before any amplification takes
place what you're doing is you're
tagging the original molecules with
these unique molecular indices and when
you look at your data with
bioinformatics sophisticated
bioinformatics tools you can actually
analyze the data and not again not based
on the Pro reads anymore but also on
unique and other indices and the way
this works is basically if you see as an
example if you see five unique molecular
indices as indicated in colored
fragments if you see on the
and side if you see five unique
molecular embassies across all of these
reads that map back to Exxon 21 of EGFR
you know you've started off with
five-minute DNA RNA molecules so these
are not PCR duplicates they represent
five unique molecules however if you end
up with five reads that carry the same
in all of our index
you know you've started off with just
one transcript basically that you've
amplified over and over and you've not
started with five unique molecules you
actually only started with one that was
duplicated over and over so by
incorporating unique molecular indices
before any amplification takes place you
now have a way to differentiate between
what is a true molecule a true DNA RNA
molecule and a PCR duplicate now how do
unique molecular indices allow us to
achieve a higher level of variant
calling it's pretty much the same the
same sort of principle or or procedure
you take your your unique DNA molecules
and you assign or ligate unique
molecular indices onto the unique
fragments basically before any
amplification takes place in order to
take advantage of unique molecular
indices so if I use again the same
example of exon 21 of EGFR and I'm
trying to let's say quantify variants
that map back to exon 21 of EGFR on the
top part of this slide you see an
example of how you're using raw reads to
try to quantify the the variants that
map back to exon 21 of EGFR and again if
you see you know one mutation or one
variant popping into an individual read
out of five with raw reads it's very
difficult to discriminate between this
as being a true let's say most frequency
mutation or whether it is a PCR error
that was introduced along the the
workflow so in order to overcome this
issue we use again unique molecular
indices that are introduced into the
unique fragments before any
amplification takes place in what um
eyes allow us to do now is to actually
differentiate differentiate between a
true low-frequency mutation or an error
that was introduced along the workflow
so on the left hand
you see an example of a false variant or
an error that was introduced in the in
the piece of our steps and the reason
being is because all these five
fragments carry the same unique
molecular index but we only see the
mutation in let's say one fragment out
of five if this was a true low-frequency
mutation you should see the variance and
all of those fragments that carry the
same unique molecular index as you see
on the right hand side so by
incorporating unique molecular indices
we now have an approach to discriminate
between what is a true low frequency
mutation and what is a TCR error and now
to show you the advantages of the single
primer extension approach I mentioned
that you can achieve a higher level of
uniformity and coverage across different
regions just to give you a couple of
examples I'm showing you here some data
that compares a single prime extension
approach versus a two primer alençon
approach for for enrichment and I'm
using an rest as an example we're
looking at enrichment of exon 3 of n
grass here and what you see on the top
part of this graph is the type of
coverage that you would get using a
tooth primer applicant approach versus
single primer extension approach in
which has been introduced in the coyote
workflow on the bottom part of the slide
and then in the table you see the the
numbers represent basically the the read
depth across you know a specific region
that we're looking at and you're also
looking at the coverage range so if you
look at how exon 3 of MLS has been
covered using the 2 primer amplicon
approach versus the single primer
extension approach anti-sikh you see big
differences first the 2 primer Appleton
approach because of the issue of primer
dropouts and primary interactions you
will see a big difference in terms of
the read depth across the different
regions of exon 3 so for instance you
know half of exon 3 of an rats has been
covered at 255 x verses the other half
being covered at 12,000 X so it's a big
difference when you look at you know the
range of coverage however if you look at
how exon 3 of MLS has been covered with
the with a single prime extension
approach entire speech panels you do see
a much tighter range and you see that
all of the bases have been covered
fairly uniformly so the lowest the
lowest type of coverage that we see for
exon 3 of n rests for example is 872 but
then the maximum type of coverage is
2033 X so again what this allows us to
do is to achieve a higher degree of
uniformity across the regions that we
want to enrich and this actually now
could drop the DES price per sample
because you don't have to account for
the lonely Express or lonely covered
regions that you see let's say in a true
primer a pecan approach and then this
also allows us the single primer
extension approach allows us to achieve
a higher degree of uniformity even
compared to let's say a hybrid capture
approach so if you compare the the type
of uniformity that you see a different
depth of coverage as you see on the
right-hand side of this graph these are
different levels of coverage all the way
from 1x to 160 X and on the x-axis you
see different types of genes that have
been interrogated and on the right hand
on the left hand side you see basically
the percent of of bases of these genes
that have been covered at a specific
depth of coverage so if I look at the
very first row at 1x you see fairly
uniform coverage whether you're using
single primer extension approaches or
hybrid capture approaches and the same
is true for 10x coverage 20x coverage
but as you increase the coverage across
the regions of interest you start seeing
a molar degree of uniformity and hybrid
capture approaches compared to the
single primer expansion approach in in
indicated panels which basically tells
us that the the single term extension
approaching the case these panels are
going to is going to allow you to
basically achieve a higher degree of
uniformity which means that the your
genes are going to be more uniform
uniformly covered regardless of of the
type of genes that you go after
so how does the workflow look like I
mentioned before that you're you know
we assign unique molecular indices
before any amplification takes place and
this is shown here at a high level
basically you take your input DNA and
the workflow tolerates as little as 10
nanograms of input DNA that DNA gets
fragmented in dramatically in a single
enzyme attic reaction to basically
produce smaller fragments the smaller
fragments are then also and repaired and
a tailed before library construction the
next step after fragmentation is unique
molecular indices assignment and library
construction this is where you are like
ating adapters to the ends of the DNA
fragments that you generated in the
first step and these adapters also
contain unique molecular indices so in
this second step you're basically
constructing your library to include
unique molecular indices and then in the
third step is the single primer
extension approach - - for enrichment so
you've generated your libraries and then
in the third step you're going to enrich
for your lesions using a single primary
extension approach and remember all of
the primers that are required has been
proved into an individual pool of
primers and once you've enriched all
your regions that the last step is to go
through library application where you
can multiplex up to 384 samples per per
sequencing run and in the entire
workflow going from extracted DNA all
the way to libraries that can be
quantified and sequenced is basically a
one day workflow and last but not least
the the way we've we've built these
solutions is basically a sample to
inside approach which means that we're
not only providing you know the the DES
panel itself and the indexes that are
required for library construction but
the chemistry is always married to
analysis pipeline sophisticated analysis
pipeline that can analyze data not just
based on raw leads but also unique
molecular indices as well interpretation
tools so if you look at look at the
expanded carrier screening panel this
sample - inside approach that we've
taken for it for this type of panel will
basically give you access to proprietary
pcr chemistry's - in which GC which
regions in the panel box and you also
have primers that are based on single
primer extension approaches for
enhancing
enhanced uniformity in addition to the
panel box you also need an index box
this is the sequence or specific part of
this workflow the panel box itself is
actually sequencer agnostic in the sense
that you could use the same chemistry
for enrichment whether using the
Illumina platforms or ion torrent
platforms
however the index box is sequence or
specific in the sense that you have to
choose you know an index box that is
compatible with your sequencer and this
box contains the molecularly bar-coded
library adapters to incorporate the
ignore internal indices and as you'll
hear from Rupert the analysis pipelines
you know they do analyze data based on
unique molecular indices and there are
sophisticated interpretation solutions
to allow you to take the data that you
generated from the channel and interpret
it for for your purposes I will turn it
over to Rupert now
Thanks right as my colleague right and
so eloquently described the upstream
sample prep is a very optimal design to
generate high-quality raw reads and raw
data to be interpreted by our
informatics systems so when we talk
about bioinformatics people think of a
lot of different things for biomedics
but today what I want to talk really
about is about bringing knowledge to
help interpret the information that is
gleaned from the sequencing of DNA
samples if we take a look at the
universe of possible human mutations
we're just now embarking on genomics
revolution and so our knowledge is
constantly growing now no one person can
obviously know everything there is to
know about the entire domain of human
genetics so your own knowledge may be
limited to a specialized domain if you
use public crowd-sourced data bases such
as clinvar you get a lot more
information but yet this is not
representative of all there is that is
known to mankind there are other
databases such as hgmd which then
attempt to curate the entire corpus of
scientific literature to identify
disease-causing variants what I want to
show you is that hydrogen has a
proprietary knowledge base that
encompasses not just information but
proprietary information as well as its
own efforts to try and bring you the
most complete picture of known
pathogenic variants that is available to
many times
now how do we do this well we've been
doing this for almost 20 years now and
that's part of that effort was curated
over 20 million findings across the
world's literature we generate over
5,000 new findings every day across over
3 to 35,000 publications we integrate
over 35 both public and proprietary
databases and have actually the
experience of having seen over a million
human samples over our platform so you
can imagine the amount of variants that
we've come across and these variants are
covered across over 33 different disease
conditions a little bit more about the
sources of knowledge that we get it so
we get a lot of this information from
both like I said proprietary and public
sources with the proprietary ones in
pink and the public ones in white as I
said we've been doing this for almost
two decades now we update our knowledge
base on a weekly basis and we have an
army of MDS and PhDs who read manually
read over 4,000 articles a month and we
update this around 3,000 findings a day
so our heightened knowledge base hygiene
knowledge base is manually curated with
a team of experts to look at structured
molecular data as well as disease and
genotype phenotype genotype information
as well as clinic drug information
clinical trials data
we break our knowledgebase into two sort
of silence there's a red hairy disease
and somatic and then we also have our
proprietary hgmd database now I talked
about finding but let me just spend a
little time explaining what a finding is
imagine if you will that you need to
take really unstructured data in the
form of a scientific article and having
to put that into a database this is
something that can't readily be done
through machine learning because you
still need to understand context and
it's very important to understand that a
person who has some domain knowledge has
a better way of curating this context
than machine algorithms so that's why we
employ mb's and PhD to do our curation
machine algorithms we'll probably one
day be able to do this but today as we
look at the machine learning and AI
landscape it's just not as good as
expert curators so our expert curator
take this unstructured data from
literature and start to generate what is
called finding and a finding is
essentially pulling nuggets of
information from a scientific article
such as what gene was mentioned in that
article
what was the alteration in that gene and
some of the details of that alteration
was there any mention of clinical effect
or clinical property measured was there
any information about drugs and if so
what were the prior treatment and
treatment details whether the cancer
type what type of cancer
London wasn't and what their number of
patients that were tested and with the
cancer type alteration what stage of
tumor was it you take that information
and you put it into a non structured
knowledge base and when you have that
information in a knowledge rate you can
now compute across that knowledge base
to auto to applying relationships that
are explicit versus implicit generation
to generate a one sentence nugget of
information which we call a finding and
here's an example on the finding that is
pulling these various nodes of
information from the knowledge base to
generate the sentence so human mutation
mutants human EGF protein so this is the
gene information this part substitution
P dot resulting as NC dot is the
alteration detail increases the
resistance and this is that clinical
effect and the clinical property
measured and then if there's drug
information to a
zd9 to nine one treatment in EGF are
nineteen exon nineteen activate so this
entire sentence is auto-generated
because we took the time to extract this
information from a scientific article
into a knowledge base and when we do
that we're essentially growing this
knowledge base both from not just
scientific literature but from clinical
trials information from drug labels
professional guidelines and various
database to accumulate knowledge into
this knowledge base and this allow not
just scalability but the availability to
then take a lot of this information to
validate certain criteria of the ACMG
class
scheme to aid in the computation of the
classification when we talk about
curating of the scientific literature we
talk about the clinical breath and the
clinical death the clinical breath can
be defined as how large is the domain of
knowledge and that can be defined as the
number of unique variants what a number
of the unique genes that are curated
clinical death on the other hand is how
deep or rich is the knowledge being
extracted so for every variant or gene
what is the total number of citations
that we were able to read and then for
each paper that we read what information
are we pulling out for example how many
clinical cases were mentioned what drugs
what dosage all of that information we
take a look at the breadth of coverage
this was a survey that I did of the
knowledge base back in February of 2019
and what we found was if you only looked
at clinically relevant variants in a
database such as clinvar you'll find
that clinvar has around 5,300 clinically
relevant genes the knowledge base on the
other hand had all of that plus and
another twelve thirteen thousand genes
covered so the knowledge base has about
3.4 times more genes and covered the
clinvar if you take a look at the number
of clinically relevant variants a good
clinvar is just under 200,000 but the
knowledge base has that amount plus
another over 700,000 clinically relevant
variants so very impressive in the
mountain dollish that we have compared
to just public sources but if you take a
look at a hypothetical panel of 59 genes
ACMG
9 you'll see that the total number of
variants across those 59 gene clinvar is
around 46 and a half a little more than
forty six and a half thousand clinically
relevant variants if you use a
proprietary database such as hgmd
there's almost twice as much around 80
1000 the knowledge base combines the
clinvar information as well as the hgmd
information plus another 22,000 unique
clinically relevant variants that you
were lying in clinvar plus hgmd
and then in terms of the depth of
coverage how many publications per
variant you'll see that clinvar not all
variants will have publications so that
information is not as easily to eat it
again hgmd has around eleven thousand
and eleven and a half thousand
publications for all their variants that
they have across those 59 genes but the
kaiser knowledgebase
has almost four times as many as HTM P
and the reason why is because
hgmd really just identifies the first
mention the first publication that
mentions that clinically relevant
variants or as the client knowledgebase
doesn't just read that first article but
then all subsequent article after that
so we strive to to reach all
publications for that particular variant
from the first time it's described to
the present
so why is it important to have all this
information well in 2007 there was a lab
that classified a child s DN 1 a
mutation as a very enough unknown
significance and because of that
classification the child's doctor didn't
alter in his treatment and as a result
he died a year later well the mom wanted
to go back and look at those variants
and parts for family planning process
and realized that back then in 2007
there was actually two papers in June of
20 2006 15 March up to heaven that could
have provided sufficient evidence to
classify her son's mutation in a
different way
in fact the March 2007 paper had a
clinical observation of a patient with
the exact mutation and the exact same
disease so she she says that if that lab
had read that paper maybe they would
have reclassified her son's mutation as
pathogenic or likely pathogenic and
possibly change the course of treatment
and so it's really important to have
access to the most comprehensive and
timely knowledge for proper assessments
and what can we find
what can you improve when you have more
knowledge and we did some benchmarking
and this is an example of looking at
Lynch syndrome variants we looked at
around 180 variants in clinvar and saw
and compared how those variants would
have been classified using not just the
publicly available information but also
hide your knowledge base and what we
found was when you apply the kaijin
knowledge base what you essentially do
is reduce the number of the us's
out of that one
eighty down by 27 percent and
reclassified those video SS to likely
pathogenic pathogenic or likely benign
and benign and so more knowledge helps
resolve these video SS which are really
a challenge for labs we don't have done
a similar comparison with cardiology and
cardiovascular bearings and found even
greater reductions of video SS by 33
percent so really the value of having
knowledge is to give greater accuracy in
classifying these variants now I want to
talk about carrier screening now the
opportunity for carrier screening
currently in 2009 is very high mainly
because of higher adoption rates of
carrier screening by the general
population around the world but also
that there is not a lot of labs around
the world that are offering expanded
carrier screening and if you take a look
at genetic testing a lot of people talk
about cancer testing the really prenatal
and carrier screening testing accounts
for a greater volume of genetic tests
than oncology so it's a huge market that
still has a lot of girls and very few
players and in a recent conference call
last year the CEO of myriad at the time
of the acquisition of council has
suggested that we're only starting to
see growth accelerating for carrier
screening and so this represents a
growth of around 16 percent cumulative
growth rate in the
a couple of years and the market has
only been 25% penetrated in the US and
much lower in other parts of the world
such as Europe and in Asia so why
carrier screening well for the patient
for their couples it's a low-risk test
the result of that test doesn't really
affect the patient or the subject itself
all it does is provides information to
inform family planning and it has more
information than ni PT for payers either
private or it reduces the lifetime cost
per subscriber last year last week and
the largest just got FDA approval of a
new SMA drug it's a drug that treats SMA
it's a one-time-use drug so that's good
but the cost of that one-time uses 2.1
million dollars
so imagine a private insurance company
that has to cover a newborn that has SMA
it's going to cost two point 1 million
it'd be great if they can avoid that
caught by screening for parents that
might Harbor a risk for SMA and then
proper family planning can result in a
healthy baby that doesn't have SMA and
reduce that cost for lab is actually a
great way of accessing a high-growth
market and once you have that market is
adjacent to a directed consumer market
funding for such a test carrier
screening is available there's certain
code certainly coverage by many private
insurance companies here in the US but
we're also seeing a lot of government
payers starting to pay for carrier
screening particularly in the middle
we're and such rare diseases are
actually pretty common and then also
consumers and parents are willing to pay
for this test out-of-pocket and then
finally for last wanting to justify the
business case of getting into genetic
testing this is a great use case to get
into genetic testing because of all the
reasons above but it's considered a low
test so there's a lower sort of FDA
barrier to getting into this test and
then finally with the investment that
they've made in purchasing the
sequencing equipment putting together
the bottom tramatic pipeline and very
little incremental cost they can
introduce adjacent testing for ni PG PG
SP T V or newborn screening as a way to
upsell the existing channels they've
created through carrier screen and then
further they can also walk into oncology
testing with that infrastructure that
they've built out but getting into
expanded carrier testing is not without
its challenges and some of these
challenges include how do you properly
design a panel and what about
alternative assays to cover difficult
regions and at the beginning of this
talk my colleague ie has talked about
how we put together this panel and the
chemistry used to improve the
sensitivity and specificity of this
panel but as part of the design of the
panel you want to take a look at what
genes and conditions are covered so you
want to make sure that it covers some of
the ACMG genes but also the ACOG
recommended conditions for carriers you
want to also make sure that whatever
condition is reported half of
actionability also because this is a
business you want to make sure that
those conditions that are covered are
reimbursable by both private and public
payers as well you may want to use this
panel in addition for carrier screening
maybe to possibly use this panel for PGS
PGD or even newborn screening so the
other thing that's also a challenge is
before you launch attempt you need to
pre to rate these genes and novel
variants in a way to reduce the amount
of time and effort in interpreting the
variants that come out of this panel the
very interpretation is also challenging
because you need to get access to
genetic expertise to interpret these
variants but also to maintain an
up-to-date knowledge base so that you're
always current with the literature and
not run into that situation where that
lab had misclassified that child's very
and then finally you need to do the
reporting and so to generate a report
template and to generate disease
statistics and risk reproductive risk is
something that you also need to consider
as part of your offering and then
finally genetic counseling to help
physicians understand the results or
even to patients to understand those
results so I want to talk about the
Precure ation challenge so before
launching a lab you typically want to
know beforehand all the variants that
you're likely to encounter through this
testing now if a lab were to do this on
their own they would access publicly
available sources and identify all the
variants to the genes that were in that
panel and if they read all those papers
and get all that information they could
probably Precure ate a lot of those
genes but after a certain period say
after 10,000 tests they're going to
start encountering more variants that
was not seen in the public domain
that's one thing the other thing is to
do that pre curation can take a long
time
if you were to look at a gene panel a
panel of around 200 genes
it could take around seven months to do
that duration now if you get typed if
you partner with kaijin to do the pre
duration we can curate much more
variants including variants that are not
found in the public domain and give you
very experience that you would have
after seeing one hundred thousand
variants and even after 100 thousand
variants you never get to a point of
zero nominal variants and in our own
internal testing we've seen that a gene
panel of around 200 genes will still
generate on average one two three
nominal varies after hundred thousand
test has been performed so the advantage
of the hydrogen expanding carriers being
is we have pre 2 rated these 200 genes
for you so that not only do you save
time but you get a more comprehensive
view of likely normal variants that
you're going to encounter so again the
reason who will pre to rate is to
quickly bank the knowledge of reportable
variants this knowledge then allows you
to accurately classified report these
variants and on also to scale your
operations
public sources are not as complete and
that information is not necessarily of
high quality it lacks the depth of
knowledge in terms of clinical case
counselor functional studies there's
possible articles that are missing and
really it takes a long time to read
through all those articles and
through all those clinvar cases so the
panel has been matched by our expert
curators and so that panel of 200
conditions already comes with the
praetor ation some of those genes are
what we call certified coverage or
bibliographic coverage genes that are
certified coverage have the findings
displayed in the user interface of our
interpretation tool which I'll explain
later
and the bibliographic coverage means
that we know we know of papers that have
mentioned of those particular mutations
we just haven't entered that information
into the knowledge base but is that we
would recommend all along reading and
then it's our job to maintain the
currency of the literature coverage for
these expanded carrier screening genes
and to perform weekly updates of this
knowledge so the value we have with this
particular ets panel is that you can let
us do the reading for you and the
knowledge leverages all 28a CMG criteria
to accurately assess the classification
of the detective variant because we've
found all this information and put it
into a database we can pull up quickly
pull up the evidence and the cited
article to show you the evidence and
make this evidence available at your
fingertips
and this results in greater efficiency
and accuracy of your
various interpretation so the other
thing as part of the effort that we can
provide is if you don't use our panel
you can create your own custom panel and
we do provide a service that will help
Preeti rate your panel for you and that
process is essentially identifying a
list of genes in that panel we will work
with you to see what genes we already
cover and ones that we don't and quickly
prepare a statement of work to curate
the gap in coverage and then finally
deliver that content for your entire
test panel as well as all reported
clinical cases which is very important
for triggering the ps4 and the ps4
criteria of a CMP classification scheme
and so the value for that is by using us
to preach your rate we can reduce the
number of the u.s. variants in your own
knowledge base reduce the future manual
lookup of such variants reduce the and
clip interpretation time as well as
increase the accuracy of variant
classifications
if now you now have you want to launch a
service you've launched your service and
business is growing quickly but now
you're running into a bottleneck where
you don't have enough variants scientist
to score your variants well we also
provide service to help you score your
variants so as your volume increases the
number of variants that you your team
that needs to interpret will grow
exponentially and so it's a challenge to
find scientific and clinical expertise
you to meet that growth we can help with
that
we offer varying scientists that can
help with your variant scoring
capabilities we do this by identifying
the test that you want to do and then
put together a statement of work
what established volumes and duration
you want us to help you guys
Othman scientific staff we will then
train our staff based on your own
protocol and your own reporting policy
and then the team will then build a
variant scoring team that will support
your clinical activities and then
deliver any final report for you guys
for the lab director to sign up so the
value here is to quickly scale your very
scientific team that faithfully
reproduces your labs reporting policy
it's essentially varying scientists
on-demand and provides you immediate
access to highly skilled and scientific
expertise so next I want to talk about a
case study that has benefited from
access to not just a knowledge base but
the preacher ation of their variants so
counsel presented this information at
ESA shg in 2007 where they found that
they their business was scaling scaling
up incredibly and they just couldn't
hire enough scientists and so they
wanted to find a automated solution that
would allow their existing team to scale
their operation but before making that
decision they want to make sure that
whatever systems they moved into had the
same level of accuracy as their own
manual system and so what they found was
comparing their manual effort with the
hygiene methods that there was a lot of
effort in terms of number of articles
for the variants that they came across
there was a lot of overlap between what
hydrogen and count
manual effort found the kaijin found
many more articles that they our team
was missing out on and then only a few
were hydrogen was missing on but more
importantly a lot of this information
provided a classification that was
almost identical to their own manual
effort which gave them greater
confidence that switching over to cotton
will not decrease the quality of their
work
more importantly they found that the
median variant search was reduced about
80 percent so not only what the quality
just was good but each user spent 80
percent less time or the other way
around
each scientist can scale fivefold their
existing capacity and then finally we
also present provide a report for the
carrier screening test this report
includes a clear result of what the
final output the test result is a
description of the test whether it
calculates the reproductive risk based
on the result of that test and allows a
section for the lab director to sign to
test out this is the summary page if you
go into the variant details page but
again reiterates the condition the
mutation detected and what the
interpretation of that mutation is for
diseases that are more obscure that the
disease definition as well as the
disease prevalence it also goes into the
sequencing method and the test limits
and this is interpretive material that
is based on the Chi seek expected
carrier screening panel so if you use
the expanded carrier screening panel or
mcian this information is already there
you don't need to recreate that
nation so this entire informatics
solution really sort of dovetails with
the expanded carrier Chi seek panel to
provide comprehensive knowledge
Precure ation accurate accurate
interpretation of variants as well as
reporting and so with that I close out
and open it up to any questions